.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS TOM BEVIN
PRESIDENT AND CO-FOUNDER OF REAL
CLEAR POLITICS AND BRIAN
KILMEADE FOX AND FRIENDS COHOST
AND AUTHOR OF THE PRESIDENT AND
THE FREEDOM FIGHTER NOW OUT IN
PAPER BACK.
HE'S ALSO THE HOST, OF COURSE,
ONE NATION AIRING SATURDAYS AT
8:00 P.M.
TOM, IT TURNS OUT THAT THESE GOP
CANDIDATES WITH NO EXPERIENCE,
IN MANY CASES ARE CONNECTING
WITH THE CONCERNS OF EVERYDAY
AMERICANS IN THEIR STATES AND
DISTRICTS, BETTER THAN THE
DEMOCRATS WHO MAY BE THE
INCUMBENTS.
>> YEAH, AND I THINK THEY'VE ALL
ACQUITTED THEMSELVES WELL IN THE
DEBATES THEY'VE HAD.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT JD VANCE IN
OHIO AND HERSCHEL WALKER
OUTPERFORMED EXPECTATIONS IN HIS
DEBATE IN GEORGIA, BLAKE MASTERS
CERTAINLY HAD A STRONGS DEBATE
PERFORMANCE IN ARIZONA.
AND SO -- AND YOU LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES, THE ONE
YOU DIDN'T MENTION IN YOUR ANGLE
IS MANNED LA BARNES IN
WISCONSIN, ANOTHER, WHO IS SEEN
AS A RISING STAR IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, RON JOHNSON IS
WELL UP IN THE POLLS THERE NOW
LEADING IN ALL THE POLLS
EXTENDING HIS LEAD THERE, AND
SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK DEMOCRATS
ARE THE WHENS ARE LOOKING AT
THEIR CANDIDATES AND THINKING,
OH, BOY, MAYBE THEY WEREN'T AS
GOOD AS WE THOUGHT THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY.
>> Laura: WELL, BRIAN, CHUCK
SCHUMER WAS CAUGHT ON A HOT MIC
TODAY TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRATS
CHANCES IN THE MIDTERMS, CHECK
THIS OUT.
>>
>> Laura: BRIAN HE SAID THE
DEBATE DIDN'T HURT MUCH IN
PENNSYLVANIA?
OZ IS UP BY 3.
>> RIGHT.
BY THE WAY HOW DOES HE KNOW?
HE'S SMILING AND CHEERLEADING.
BUT IT IS INTERESTING TO CATCH
THE HOT MIC.
NO MATTER HOW EXPERIENCED YOU
ARE IN POLITICS THEY SEEM TO
NEVER UNDERSTAND THE MICROPHONE
IS ALWAYS ON.
REMEMBER WHEN HE CALLED PETER
DOOCY, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES A STUPID BLANK.
COUPLE THINGS ON YOUR MONOLOGUE
YOU NAILED IT IN MANY RESPECTS.
ANOTHER RESPECT IS THIS.
THERE'S A BELIEF IN WASHINGTON
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE EXPERIENCE
AS A POLITICIAN TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL POLITICIAN.
I THINK WE SCREWED UP THE JOB
DESCRIPTION.
THE JOB DESCRIPTION IS SENIORS.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXECUTE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT PUT ME THERE ALONG
WITH REPRESENT AND ON THE BEST
THINGS IN THE INTEREST OF MY
COUNTRY, OKAY, AND PARTY FITS
IN.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO
SPEND 30 YEARS DOING IT.
YOU CAN BE IN BUSINESS, YOU CAN
BE IN MEDICINE, YOU CAN BE IN
SPORTS.
YOU CAN BE MULTIFACETED IN TERMS
OF HERSCHEL WALKER HE HAS
BUSINESS AS WELL.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T DO IT THEY
SAY, WELL, INSPEARED.
YEAH, AT WHAT?
KARI LAKE IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE CANDIDATES I HAVE
SEEN COME OUT OF THE BOX.
SHE HAS NO POLITICAL EXPERIENCE
BUT 30 YEARS DOING WHAT YOU DO,
AN OUTSTANDING BROADCASTER.
YOU COULD PROBABLY STEP RIGHT
IN, LAURA INGRAHAM HAS NO
EXPERIENCE.
AT WHAT?
SERVING YOUR COUNTRY?
DOING WHAT'S BEST?
UNDERSTANDING ISSUES?
AND I THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
REALLY -- I KNOW HE'S PRETTY
MUCH NOT ON THE BALLOT
DEFINITELY BUT HE IS KIND OF
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BLAKE MASTERS
AND JD VANCE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HERSCHEL WALKER, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT EVEN MARCO RUBIO HE'S
STUMPING FOR SURELY THESE ARE
CANDIDATES, KARI LAKE, LOT OF
PEOPLE THEY DIDN'T GET BEHIND
AND TRUMP SAID THAT'S MY PICK
AND THEY SAID WE'RE IN TROUBLE
AND LITTLE BY LITTLE THESE
CANDIDATES ENDED UP REALLY
PROVING THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: AND THE CONVENTIONAL
WISDOM, ESTABLISHMENT
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM IS WRONG
AGAIN IN WASHINGTON BUT TOM THE
WASHINGTON POST REVEALED I THINK
HOW DESPERATE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GETTING, BECAUSE ON WEDNESDAY,
THEY PUMPED ABOUT $6.3 MILLION
WORTH OF ADS INTO A TRIO OF
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS IN NEW
YORK AND NEW JERSEY.
AND FIRST LADY JILL BIDEN SPENT
THE AFTERNOON IN RHODE ISLAND
TRYING TO HELP SAVE A DEMOCRAT
RUNNING THERE IN A DISTRICT HER
HUSBAND CARRIED BY ALMOST 14
POINTS.
AND THEN I GUESS HE'S TRYING TO
SHORE UP HOCHUL IN NEW YORK,
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT HOCHUL
GETTING ENOUGH TURNOUT IN NEW
YORK CITY.
IN A POLITICO PIECE TONIGHT TOM,
THIS IS GETTING VERY
INTERESTING.
>> YEAH.
IT'S -- THE NORTHEAST IS NOT
LOOKING GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE PROBLEMS EVERYWHERE,
ACROSS THE BOARD.
THERE WAS A STORY EARLIER THIS
WEEK THAT DEMOCRATS ARE POURING
MILLIONS INTO WASHINGTON STATE
TO SHORE UP PATTY MURRAY AGAINST
TIFFANY SMILEY THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE UP THERE WHO'S WITHIN
STRIKING DISTANCE.
AND YOU'VE SEEN THESE POLLS POP
UP.
THERE WAS A POLL IN INN ME THAT
SHOWED THE GOVERNOR'S RACE THERE
CLOSE, WHICH WAS A BIT SHOCKING.
SO, YEAH.
LOOK, I THINK THE GENERAL
CONSENSUSES AND ALL THE DATA IS
TELLING US THAT A REPUBLICAN
WAVE IS BUILDING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT YOU SEE THE
MOVEMENT IN THE SENATE RACES AND
THE HOUSE RACES AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RACES AND THE
QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
STILL TEN DAYS AWAY SO HOW BIG
WILL IT BE?
WILL IT CREST EARLY AND NOT BE
AS BIG AS PEOPLE THINK OR WILL
IT BUILD EARLY AND CRASH ON
ELECTION DAY?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN BUT
RIGHT NOW REPUBLICANS ON ARE ON
OFFENSE IN STATES AND DISTRICTS
THAT DEMOCRATS DIDN'T THINK THEY
WERE GOING TO BE PLAYING
DEFENSE.
AND THEY'RE UP AGAINST IT RIGHT
NOW, THE DEMOCRATS CERTAINLY
ARE.
>> YEAH, CRIME INFLATION AND THE
BORDER AREN'T GOING TO BE FIXED
IN TEN DAYS.
BRIAN FINALLY YOUR BOOK THE
PRESIDENT FREEDOM FIGHTERS IS
OUT IN PAPER BACK NOW.
HOW DOES THIS AND THIS STORY
RELATE TO SERVICE AND THE IDEA
THAT THE LAST THING YOU REALLY
WANT IS A PROFESSIONAL
POLITICIAN IN WASHINGTON.
YOU WANT PEOPLE WITH REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE TO RELATE TO WHAT'S
GOING TO NOW IN THE LIVES OF
EVERYDAY PEOPLE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
THE STORY MOST WRITTEN ABOUT
PRESIDENT, FREDERICK DOUGLASS
BORN A SLAVE, DON'T TELL ME YOU
HAVE HEAD WINS IF THIS GUY CAN
BE BORN A SLAVE AND WITHIN SEVEN
YEARS OF FREEDOM CAN BE ONE OF
THE MOST WELL RESPECTED PEOPLE
IN THE FREE WORLD BECAUSE HE
WENT TO EUROPE AND ESTABLISHED
HIMSELF.
ABOUT YOU THE NUMBER TWO SLOT ON
EVERY LIST IS EDUCATION.
WE ARE LEARNING NOT TO RESPECT
LINCOLN AND DOUGLAS AND AMERICAN
FOUNDING FATHERS AND THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN FAMILY NOT POLITICALLY
ORIENTED AND NOT WOKE IS
OUTRAGED BY THIS.
AND THIS WHOLE WAR ON HISTORY.
THIS IS LIKE A PUSHBACK, COLD
FACTS.
AND ALL I GET FROM ARRANGES, I
JUST DID A SIGNING AN HOUR AGO,
IS MY KIDS DON'T LEARN ANY OF
THIS.
I HAVE TO TELL THEM THIS.
I READ THEM IN ORDER TO OVERCOME
THE HISTORY THEY'RE NOT LEARNING
IN SCHOOL.
AND I THINK ABOUT YOUNGKIN,
YOUNGKIN TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION, THINKING ABOUT THE
PARENTS STANDING UP.
THEY'RE ARGUING FOR ICONIC
FIGURES IN OUR PAST NOT TO BE
TORN OFF STATUS SO WE DON'T
BECOME A NATION OF PEDESTALS.
AND OVERALL BIGGER PICTURE WITH
YOUR THEME, HIBERNATING THE WAY
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID IT IS NOT
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO WORK KATHY
HOCHUL AND JOHN FETTERMAN.
REPUBLICANS ARE HAVING SUCCESS
OUTWORKING THEIR OPPONENTS.
>> Laura: GOING OUT --
>> YEAH.
I DRILL MY PRO AMERICAN MESSAGE.
>> Laura: AND GOING OUT AND
BEING WITH THE PUSHABILITY
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE THE
CANDIDATES YOU CAN'T COCOON
YOURSE